in The Havana neighborhood of viad 30
people live in this once Posh two-story
house it's literally falling to
pieces this resident tells me his mother
was killed when one of these wooden
beams fell on top of her they let me
take a quick look
inside where the makeshift staircase
feels equally
unstable I've been living here since
1994 trying to get a proper dwelling but
there's nothing
everywhere you look homes built before
the 1959 Revolution are
collapsing yet simultaneously a
construction boom is underway not for
public housing but for
hotels last year eight enormous new
hotels were inaugurated another five
will be opened by December and more will
follow the majority are owned and
financed by gasa the Cuban military's
tourism company that owns 76% of
five-star hotels and the majority of the
rest all this while Cuba's so-called
economic engine continues to stall as
evidenced by these Exquisite old
convertibles standing idle in Old Havana
for lack of foreign
tourists for a modest fee we are taken
for a spin by Eric who explains that
millions of Cubans depend on
tourism it's a chain if I work I spend
money and others make money and so so on
and so forth it's what makes the economy
run the prohibition of cruise ships
imposed by Donald Trump has impacted us
a lot like his other
sanctions in the last 6 months only 28%
of Cuba's hotel rooms have been occupied
and US sanctions aren't the only
reason officials concede that shortages
or poor quality of food fuel
transportation and entertainment are
also discouraging visitors during the
so-called golden years when President
Barack Obama was in office this whole
area was absolutely full now as you can
see the streets are empty there are no
tourists almost anywhere so the big
question is why are they building so
many new
hotels one clue is that while emblematic
structures like the art deco Riviera
Hotel remain closed new hotels are being
built with government money on property
not being claimed in US courts by their
pre-revolution owners
many speculate that should Cuba's one
party State system eventually change
they could then be bought and sold
industry officials insist they're simply
preparing for a tourism boom comparable
to Cuba's pre-revolution days a feat
that will take more than just new hotels
Lucia Newman Al jazer
Havana make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz